الساده المشاهدين اهلا وسهلا بكم الى هذا
اللقاء الخاص مع فخامه رئيس الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه في ايران السيد ابراهيم رئيسي
فخامه الرئيس اهلا وسهلا بكم على شاشه
الجزيره ايه ابدا
معك مباشره في السؤال الاول كرئيس
للجمهوريه الاسلاميه في ايران ونحن نقترب
من ان تدخل الحرب على
غزه
شهر كامل كيف تقراون في ايران حقيقه ما
يجري في غزه من هذه الحرب بمستويات
مختلفه بسم الله الرحمن
الرح من ابتدا لازم بدونم به بندان
عزز في البدايه اود ان احيي جميع
المشاهدين الكرام واتمنى لهم
النجاح الاخبار الاخيره في منطقتنا مؤسفه
وتجرح احاسيس اي انسان حر سواء كان مسلما
ام مسيحيا ام يهوديا او اي انسان صاحب
ضمير المشاهد التي نشهدها في المنطقه يجب
ان تثير انتباه جميع اصحاب الفكر واصحاب
الراي المجازر التي يرتكبها الكيان
الصهيوني وقتل النساء والاطفال كل ذلك
تدعمه الولايات المتحده وعدد من الدول
الاوروبيه ويمكن القول ان شعوب العالم
وكثيرا من اصحاب الفكر والسياسيين يقفون
في جهه بينما تقف الاداره الامريكيه وعدد
من الدول الاوروبيه والكيان الصهيوني الذي
يعتبر كيانا زائفا في الجهه المقابله
التركيز على هذا الامر مهم جدا لكي نعرف
لماذا يقترف هذا الكيان الزائف هذه
المجازر في حق الشعب الفلسطيني الذي يعيش
في بيته وعلى ارضه الشعب الذي يقاوم
ويواصل الصمود ومستعد لان يستشهد لكنه لا
يترك ارضه بل يهزم العدو بالمقاومه
والصمود الكيان الصهيوني يواصل ظلمه للشعب
الفلسطيني على مدى 75 عاما قتل اعدادا
كبيره من الفلسطينيين وسجن كثيرا منهم
وعذبهم وهدم بيوتهم واختصب اراضيهم
الزراعيه ظلما وبهتانا ان ارض فلسطين تظهر
الكثير من الظلم الذي فرضه الكيان
الصهيوني على الشعب الفلسطيني وشعوب
المنطقه لكن هل استطاع هذا الكيان ان يمنع
الناس من المقاومه رغم الظلم الذي اقترفه
في حقهم هل نجح في دفع الشعب الى
الاستسلام وعدم التمسك بحق
وارضه ووطنه لا لم ينجح ما حدث في عمليه
طوفان الاقصى هو نتيجه سنوات من الظلم
المفروض على فلسطين وهو ناجم عن الاساءه
الى المسجد الاقصى والقدس الشريف انه
نتيجه للتعذيب والسجون والاذى الذي لحق
بالناس كل يوم يسقط شهيد وكل يوم يتعرض
مكان او بيت للهجوم والنتيجه هي ان هذا
الغضب يتحول الى حركه مقاومه وصمود وعمليه
في طوفان الاقصى الكيان الصهيوني يعتبر
كيانا زائفا ومعادي للانسانيه الولايات
المتحده التي تدعي التزامها بحقوق الانسان
كيف تبرر دعمها للظلم والاضطهاد كيف تبرر
تسليح الكيان الصهيوني وتقديم المعدات
العسكريه له ودعمه في رايي ما يمكن
استيعابه من صمود الشعب الفلسطيني هو انهم
مقاومون ومظلوم لكنهم اقوياء في الوقت
نفسه الشعب الفلسطيني اليوم كما وصفهم
قائد الثوره هو شعب قادر لكنه مظلوم وهذا
دون شك يبشر بانتصار الشعب الفلسطيني
وحركه المقاومه نعلم بان هذا الصمود بهذا
الحجم من الاراده سيؤدي دون شك الى
انتصارهم الحرب اليوم هي حرب ارادات هناك
اراده الشعب الذي يرزح تحت ظلم واضطهاد
الكيان الاسرائيلي والولايات المتحده وفي
المقابل هناك اراده المستكبرين واراده
الظلمه وفراعنه هذا الزمن التي تتمثل في
الكيان الصهيوني وامريكا وعدد من الدول
الاوروبيه في حرب الايرادات ليس لدينا اي
شك في ان اراده الفلسطينيين الحديديه
ستنتصر والمستقبل سيكون من نصيب فلسطين
والشعب
الفلسطيني فلسطين خواهد فخامه الرئيس
اسرائيل تعتبر في ايران شركاء لحركه حماس
في المقاومه وهذا بالمعنى
التاريخي حقيقه فخامه الرئيس هل تعتبرون
انفسكم في ايران او تعتبرون ايران شريك
للمقاومه الفلسطينيه في قطاع غزه بما
حققته يوم السابع من اكتوبر في العمليات
الت سم طوفان الاقص بب نرو
مقاومت نرو برخه از
م قوات المقاومه تنهض من داخل الشعب في
فلسطين وفي لبنان وفي اي مكان في المنطقه
هؤلاء هم شعوب وشباب سائم الظلم واجتمعوا
ليدافعوا عن وطنهم وعن حقوقهم وحركه
المقاومه في فلسطين وقوات المقاومه في
فلسطين هي مجموعات نهضت من داخل الشعب
الفلسطيني وهي مجموعات لديها الوعي ومدرك
للوضع وتريد الدفاع عن شعبها وعن اراضيها
دفاعهم هو امر مشروع ونؤيد هذا الدفاع
المشروع الدفاع عن شعبهم وارضهم وعرضهم
هو حق مشروع وندعمه وقد اكدنا عده مرات
اننا ندعم حركه المقاومه الفلسطينيه لانهم
يدافعون عن حقوق شعبهم فاذا كان المقصود
هو ان قوات المقاومه مدعومه من جانب
الجمهوريه الاسلاميه الايرانيه فهذا تم
تاكيده عده مرات وبصوت عال من جانبنا كما
يقول الامام علي في كلامه في اخر لحظات
عمره الشريف كل الظالم خصما وللمظلوم عونا
نحارب الظلم ونعتقد ان الظلم لن يبقى
وايامه لم تعد كثيره ان للحق دوله وللباطل
جوله الباطل يمكن ان يجول لفتره لكنه
سيتلاشى ولن يدوم وما يبقى هو الحق لا
يمكنهم ان يضيعوا حق الشعب الفلسطيني
الجمهوريه الاسلاميه الايرانيه هي
المدافعه عن حركه المقاومه في مواجهه
الظلمه
والمستكبرين لكن اذا كان المقصود هو انه
اذا تحركت قوات المقاومه في اي مكان وانه
يتم بامر من الجمهوريه الاسلاميه
الايرانيه او اننا نطلب منهم ان يتخذوا
قرارات واجراءات معينه فالجواب هنا هو لا
المقاومه تتخذ القرارات وتنفذها بشكل
مستقل وهم من يتخذون القرار وينفذون ه
بناء على تقديراتهم للاوضاع ومراقبه
الامور ويقيمون الخطوات التي يجب ان
يتخذوها وعندها يتخذون القرار وكما هو
معلن في سياساتنا فان المقاومه الفلسطينيه
والمقاومه في المنطقه تحظى بدعمنا لانها
تدافع عن الاوطان لكن اتخاذ القرار
وتنفيذه بالكامل من جانب قاده المقاومه
هذا هو الوضع الحالي وما سيكون عليه في
المستقبل ايضا مقاومت بوده و هست بعد ازهم
خواهد
بود فخامت الرس ايران وعبر وزير
خارجيتها تحركت منذ اليوم الاول
سياسيا ودبلوماسيا بشكل واسع مع الدول
العربيه مع الدول الاسلاميه والهدف صياغه
موقف
اقليمي اسلامي يدفع
باتجاه وقف اطلاق النار وادخال المساعدات
الانسانيه الى قطاع غزه وفتح المعابر
وانتم فخامه الرئيس تلقيتم عده اتصالات من
زعماء في العالم العربي والعالم
اسلامي في هذا الشق السياسي الدبلوماسي
الان حقيقه فخامه الرئيس هل هناك انجاز
تحقيق شيء ما من هذا المسار السياسي
الدبلوماسي حتى الان وصلتم الى شيء ما
بالمعنى الاقليمي ولا زلتم حتى اليوم كان
هناك اتصال بينكم فخامه الرئيس ومع امير
دوله قطر
مثلا مسئله فلسطين مسله اول جهان اسلام
آ قدس شف موضوع مهم و محور برا قض فلسط قض
العالم الاسلامي الاولى تحرير القدس
الشريف موضوع مهم وجوهري للامه الاسلاميه
كاهم قضيه يجب ان تحظى باهتمام كافه الدول
الاسلاميه علاقاتنا مع الدول الاسلاميه
وزعماء هذه الدول ووزراء خارجيتها
والدبلوماسيه هي التعاون مع الدول
الاسلاميه في هذه المساله المهمه للغايه
قضيه فلسطين تعتبر امرا ضروريا فمنذ بدايه
هذه الحرب الاخيره بدانا اتصالاتنا ولا شك
ان هذا كان مؤثر في تقريب وجهات النظر
وسيكون له تاثير خلال الفتره
القادمه اليوم لا يوجد اي شك من جانب اي
طرف بضروره وقف اطلاق النار بشكل عاجل
وكسر الحصار عن غزه الجميع مهتم بموضوع
ايصال المساعدات الانسانيه لاهالي غزه
المظلومين وهذا مطلب يجب ان
ينفذ لهذا السبب يجب ان يؤدي التعاون لوقف
اطلاق النار في اقرب فرصه وهذا امر يتحقق
عبر التعاون والتشاور والمفاوضات المستمره
هذا الامر متفق عليه من جانب الدول كافه
ويجب ان ينفذ بشكل سريع في المقابل
الولايات المتحده هي من الاطراف التي
تعارض وتعرقل الوصول الى وقف اطلاق النار
وايضا هناك عدد من الدول الاوروبيه تعطل
ذلك الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده اعلنت
عن نتيجه تصويتها على قرار وقف اطلاق
النار بشكل عاجل وجميع دول العالم
باستثناء عدد من الدول صوتت لصالح القرار
وهذا يدل على ان العالم وشعوب العالم
لديها الاراده لوقف اطلاق النار في اقرب
فرصه وعندما تعارض الولايات المتحده وعدد
من الدول الاوروبيه وقف اطلاق النار فهذا
يعني ان النساء والاطفال سوف يتم
استهدافهم ونحن نشهد المدنيين الذين ليس
لديهم اي ذنب في غزه في كل ساعه هذا يعني
ان ايادي الولايات المتحده وعدد من الدول
الاوروبيه والكيان الصهيوني الذي يرتكب
هذه المجازر ملطخه بدماء النساء
والاطفال وفي الحقيقه هذه المجازر لن تسجل
فقط باسم الكيان الصهيوني بل ستسجل باسم
كافه داعمي الكيان الصهيوني جميع الدول
تؤيد موضوع وقف اطلاق النار المساعدات
الانسانيه لاهالي غزه الذين قطع عنهم
الماء والغذاء والدواء لكن الولايات
المتحده تعارض هذا الموضوع والدول
الاوروبيه التي وقعت على بيان مشترك مع
امريكا يجب ان تكون مسؤوله امام الله
وامام الشعوب والضمائر الواعيه والتاريخ
وهذه الجرائم الكبرى تسجل عليهم جميعا
لهذا السبب فاننا في سياستنا الخارجيه
نؤمن بالتعاون مع الدول المجاوره والدول
الاسلاميه ودول المنطقه وخارجها لايجاد
موقف موحد ونعتقد اليوم بان هذا الاجماع
تم تحقيقه وهناك اجماع دولي ضد الكيان
الصهيوني وحتى يكون هذا الاجماع مؤثرا يجب
ان تتواصل الاتصالات بشكل دائم لمتابعه
المواضيع لتتمكن الدول التي لديها مواقف
متشابهه من متابعه هذا الموضوع لتحقيق
مطالب الشعب الفلسطيني وشعوب العالم
والشعوب التي تخرج في الشارع وتد بالظلم
الامريكي وظلم الكيان الصهيوني وتدعم
الشعب الفلسطيني هذا المطلب يجب ان يتحقق
سعا امر رو ظلم رج صون رو و به نفع و به
دفاع از مردم فلسط فرد مزن خواست هر سعتر
تحققن فخامه الرس سؤال
مباشر ما هي الخطوط
الحمراء التي اذا ما تجاوزتها
اسرائيل سيكون هناك سياسه ايرانيه مختلفه
انتم في ايران هل لديكم خطوط حمراء حقيقه
مما يجري في غزه منذ اكثر من 20 يوم تحت
هذا القصف والاستهداف المباشر من قبل
اسرائل اونه امروز داره در غزه مذره همه
خطوط قرمز اس رجم صون داره خطوط رو
الاحداث التي نشدها في غزه جميعها خطوط
حمراء يتم تجاوزها من جانب الكيان
الصهيوني قتل النساء والاطفال ومقتل اكثر
من 3 الاف طفل لا يقبله اي منطق او ضمير
انساني قتل النساء والهجوم على المستشفيات
والمساجد والكنائس والهجوم على كافه
المراكز ايضا لا يقبله اي منطق كم عدد
الصحفيين الذين استشهدوا على يد هذا
الكيان الخبر الذي سمعته عن المراسل
الفلسطيني العزيز الذي يعمل في قناه
الجزيره والذي قام بتكفين عائلته بنفسه
وقف ال جانب جثام احبا فلسط خانواده خودش
رو با دستان
خودش
كنده
ونار بدن بجان عزش حاضر شده لن خم به ابرو
نورده لنه لم ينحني وقال ان هؤلاء جميعا
رحلوا في طريق فلسطين وظل يقول حسبنا الله
ونعم الوكيل حسبنا الله و نعم الو خل قت
داره هذا امر ثمين للغايه الطفل الصغير
الذي وقف يلقن اخاه الشهاده هذا عمل بطلي
من جانب شخص مؤمن ونشهد ان الاطفال
والنساء والشيوخ والشباب في فلسطين هم
اناس مؤمنون ومستعدون شهاده مقابل عدم
مغادره ارضهم ويبدون المقاومه والصمود حا
به
شها سرزمين خشون تر ننن مقاومت وستاد وار
از خشون نشون بدن ا منطق يقبل ان يقتل هذا
العدد من الصحفيين هذه خطوط حمراء في جميع
انحاء العالم الصحفيون يقومون بنقل
الاخبار وهؤلاء يقومون بقتل الصحفيين لمنع
نقل الاخبار الى العالم
يقومون بق شبكات الاتص وال حت لا يتمص
الاخبار الى شعوب العالم لكن شعوب العالم
اليوم باتت واعيه وفي كافه انحاء العالم
نشهد احتجاجات ضد الكيان الصهيون تمام
مردم بار شد البته من با از شبه الجزره هم
تقر بن طبعا يجب ان اش بعمل شبكه الجزره
التي لعبت دورا جيدا في نقل الحقيقه بكل
اشكالها النوات التي تمكنت من نقل صوت
الشعب الفلسطيني الى شعوب العالم قامت
بدور مهم كوسيله اعلام تمكنت من نقل
الاخبار الى العالم اما وسائل الاعلام
التي اهملت هذا الامر وفرضت رقابه على صوت
الشعب الفلسطيني ولم تسمح بنقل هذه
الاصوات الى شعوب العالم هؤلاء يجب ان تتم
محاسبتهم امام الله والضمائر والاجيال
القادمه لان ذلك يعتبر ايضا نوعا من الظلم
بحق الشعب الفلسطيني لهذا اقول ان هذا
الكيان تخطى خطوطا حمراء كثيره واليوم
الجمهوريه الاسلاميه الايرانيه تتابع
وستقوم بما عليها من التزامات بهذا الخصوص
من خلال العمل مع الدول المختلفه وسنواصل
المتابعه باهتمام لمسار وقف اطلاق النار
ورفع الحصار وايصال المساعدات وتقديم
العون للشعب الفلسطيني المظلوم سنواصل
جهودنا في هذا الاطار ولن نتعب
دفان و همم به مظلوم فلسط و خودم رو همن
خواه داشت و نسبت به و دفاع از مردم فلسط
هرز خسته نخه شد فخامه الرئيس حقيقه دعني
انقل
لك بعض ما يقال في العالم العربي
والاسلامي اي هناك في العالم العربي وفي
العالم الاسلامي من ينتقد ايران هناك من
يعتب على ايران وهناك من يهاجم حتى ايران
على قاعده بان ايران هي صاحبه مشروع في
المنطقه ودوله اقليميه
كبيره وهذا المشروع هو مشروع محور
المقاومه وايران تقول بانها هي زعيمه هذا
المشروع او لنقل هي الاخ الاكبر
في
هذا المشروع هؤلاء يقولون بانهم لم يروا
حتى الان
عملا قويا عسكريا من قبل ايران فيما يخص
المقاومه الفلسطينيه في غزه منذ 20 يوم
الى الان هل هناك ربما اعمال تقوم بها
ايران ولا تعلن عنها مثلا ام ان هذا
الموضوع متروك للتنسيق بين قاده محور
المقاومه ليروا السيناريو الافضل والتوقيت
الافضل اليوم الولايات المتحده تزود
الكيان الصهيوني بكافه التجهيزات والاسلحه
وتطلب من باقي حركات المقاومه في المنطقه
ان تتخذ اي اجراء ولهذا اقول ان المقاومه
هي حركه عفويه تنبع من داخل الشعب من خلال
الشباب والناس للدفاع عن وطنهم هذا السؤال
ي على الدول او الاقلام التي تنتقد ايران
لماذا لم يدافعو هم بهذا الشكل من الدفاع
المشروع الذي يقوم به الفلسطينيون كمقاوم
على ايدي هؤلاء تم قتل 3 الاف طفل انا
اقول يجب ان يطرح هذا السؤال على هؤلاء
الاشخاص
الاطراف التي توجه الانتقادات للجمهوريه
الاسلاميه او تطرح الاسئله بشان ذلك يجب
ان تسال لماذا انتم في ايران تدعمون الشعب
الذي يدافع
هو ماجب انم
طرح دفاش خشون بب ما ما
اعلام اعلنا عده مرات اننا ندعم حركات
المقاومه في فلسطين وفي المنطقه ونعتقد ان
على جميع الدول في العالم الاسلامي وجميع
الدول المستقله في العالم ان تدافع عن
المقاومه الفلسطينيه ما عدا تلك التي تخضع
ليمنه الولايات المتحده فضلا عن بعض الدول
الغربيه التي لها د في تاسيس الكيان
الصهيوني يجب على الدول الاسلاميه ان تدعم
القضيه الفلسطينيه وحركه المقاومه هناك
سياسيا وماليا انظر اليوم الى حركه
المقاومه الفلسطينيه كيف تقف صامده امام
الكيان الصهيوني لا احد طلب من اعزائنا في
المقاومه ان يقوموا بهذا الصمود وهذا
العمل الجاد هذا سؤالي للدول التي تدعي
انها تدافع عن حقوق الانسان وجوابي لهم لا
لم يطلب احد ذلك من المقاومه فهي صاحبه
قرارها المقاومه تم تشكيلها منذ اليوم
الاول لاحتلال فلسطين منذ 75 سنه لكن هذه
الحركه شهدت صعودا وهبوطا وتم قمعها في
مرحله ما بشكل كبير وفي يوم ما عملت في
اطار حركات التحرير واليوم باتت في افضل
اوضاعها نتذكر يوم اجتمعت ست دول عربيه
لمواجهه الكيان الصهيوني في الايام السته
وهي معروفه فخامه الرئيس
امريكا ارسلت لكم اكثر من
رساله بان يجب على ايران ان لا
تتدخل في هذه المعركه الدائره في غزه ويجب
على ايران ان لا تقوم
بتوسيع الحرب لكي تشمل ساحات اخرى هل
تلقيتم هذه الرسائل الامريكيه على انها
تحذير
ام تهديد من قبل امريكا كيف تعاطيت مع هذا
الموضوع مع هذه الرسائل الامر
اونه
امرها
درها ما اعلنت عنه الولايات المتحده في
رسائلها الى المسؤولين الايرانيين ليتم
نقلها لقوات المقاومه تم الرد عليها وهذه
الردود كانت معلنه ولم تكن سريه قوات
المقاومه تمتلك امكانيه تقييم واتخاذ
القرار والجمهوريه الاسلاميه لا تعطيهم
الاوامر ونقول لامريكا انه لا يحق لها ان
تصدر الاوامر لمحور المقاومه هذه
المجموعات المقاومه نابعه من داخل المجتمع
الفلسطيني واللبناني وباقي الدول ولديها
القدره على التمييز واتخاذ القرار
والجمهوريه الاسلاميه الايرانيه لا تتخذ
القرارات بالنيابه عنهم وعلى الامريكيين
ان يدركوا هذا الامر وتم اخبارهم بشكل
واضح بذلك الحقيقه هذا امر محير للعالم
حين تقول الولايات المتحده لنا ولباقي
محور المقاومه لا تتخذ اي اجراء لكنها
تقوم بتقديم الاسلحه والمعدات العسكريه
للكيان الصهيوني وتتوقع من قوات المقاومه
والشعوب والشباب الا يتخذ اي خطوه بينما
هي تقوم بتسليح علني وكبير للكيان
الصهيوني
الذي يستخدم هذه الاسلحه والمعدات ضد
النساء والاطفال والمدنيين امام اعين
العالم ويطلبون من قوات المقاومه انلا
يقوموا باي رد فعل او تنفيذ اي عمليات كيف
يمكن لهذا الامر ان يكون مقبولا الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه الايرانيه لا تتخذ القرارات
بدلا من حركه المقاومه المقاومه هي من
تقيم الامور وتتخذ القرار لكن كما اكدنا
سابقا وبصوت عال فان محور المقاومه مدعوم
من طرف ايران وبدلا من ان يسالوا لماذا
تقوم ايران بذلك يجب ان يكون السؤال لماذا
لا يدعمونهم حركه المقاومه التي تدافع عن
وطنها دفاعا مشروعا دعمنا للمقاومه مبني
على اسس ومبادئ واضحه اعلنا عنها في
سياستنا الخارجيه باننا ندعم كل من يقوم
بالدفاع المشروع عن ارضه ووطنه لكن يجب ان
نطرح هذا السؤال على الجانب المقابل بانه
لماذا يحظى هذا الكيان الصهيوني المحتل
بدعم هذه الاطراف في امريكا والغرب ودعمهم
للكيان الصهيوني مبني على الظلم
والاستكبار بينما دعمنا لقوات المقاومه
مبني على المنطق والعدل ويقوم على الاسس
الانسانيه والاسلاميه واهمها دعم من يدافع
عن ارضه وعرضه ووطنه وشعبه اعتقد ان على
كافه دول العالم ان تقدم د دها لهؤلاء هل
يمكن ان يقول احد انه يجب ان لا يتم دعم
من يقوم بالدفاع المشروع عن نفسه هذا
سؤالي للاطراف التي لا تدعم المقاومه
ولماذا لا تفعل ذلك على الجميع ان يدعم من
يدافع عن ارضه وبيته وحياته ويجب محاسبه
المحتل على استهدافه بيوت الناس والمدنيين
العزل سؤال قرار بره را تو حملهن به خانه
وشانه تو خونه نشسته سؤال الاخر فخامه
الرئيس واضح بان رئيس الوزراء في اسرائيل
بنيامين نتنياهو يقول بشكل
معلن
بان الهدف من هذه الحرب هو القضاء بالكامل
على حركه حماس في قطاع غزه واعاده صناعه
الشرق الاوسط الجديد مره اخرى كما تريد
اسرائيل انتم حقيقه في ايران ا هل تنظرون
الى
هذا الموضوع على ان اسرائيل قادره على ان
تفعل ذلك وهل لديكم سيناريو مواجهه اذا ما
حصل ذلك حقيقه خاصه وبان تدعمون محور في
المنطقه هو محور
المقاومه ر صون و امريكا ها به ه عنوان
نمتو جان مقاومت را از ب ببرن لا قدره
للكيان الصهيوني والولايات المتحده على
القضاء على حركه المقاومه في فلسطين
والمنطقه المقاومه حاضره في نفوس الشعوب
وتجري في دم الشعب الفلسطيني عندما
تشاهدون صورا من فلسطين ستشعرون بهذا
الامر الام التي فقدت طفلها الطفل الذي
فقد امه الاب الذي فقد طفله الطفل الذي
فقد والده هؤلاء يرون حياتهم وقد دمرت
امام نواظر لكنهم غير مستعدين للتخلي عن
المقاومه هل يمكن القضاء على هذه
المقاومه هذه المقاومه غير محدوده بشخص
معين او مجموعه معينه هذا الصمود امام
الظلم والاضطهاد بات يسكن قلوب الشعب
الفلسطيني ولا يمكن القضاء عليه باي شكل
من الاشكال هذه هي نتيجه خطا في حسابات
الولايات المتحده والكيان الصهيوني على
مدى عده سنوات على مدى 75 سنه يمارسون
الظلم في حق الفلسطينيين
وفقا لهذا التقييم الخاطئ يعتقدون انهم
قادرون على القضاء على المقاومه عبر القتل
والسجن والتعذيب وفرض القيود هذا لن يحصل
ابدا ولن يتمكنوا من القضاء على المقاومه
وقد رايتم خلال السنوات الماضيه انه كلما
ازداد ظلم الكيان الصهيوني ازدادت قوه
المقاومه واليوم المقاومه باتت اقوى من اي
وقت اخر حركه المقاومه حركه قويه وتعتمد
على الله وعلى دعم كافه افراد الشعب
الفلسطيني والشعب اللبناني وباقي الشعوب
في الدول الاخرى دول العالم تعطي الحق
للجهه التي تدافع عن ارضها باستثناء
الولايات المتحده وعدد من دول الاوروبيه
التي باتت اليوم معزوله عن باقي دول
العالم المقاومه تعمل بعمل جوهري هو
الدفاع عن الوطن ونحن في الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه الايرانيه اكدنا منذ البدايه
وعلنا في سياستنا الخارجيه اننا ندعم
المقاومه الور الاسلاميه دوله قويه
والولايات المتحده تدرك ان ايران
الاسلاميه باتت اليوم اقوى من اي وقت اخر
وقوتنا تكمن في اعتمادنا على الله وعلى
شعبنا العزيز وجميع امكاناتنا وقدراتنا
التي تمكنا من تحقيقها رغم العقوبات
والتهديدات خلال هذه السنوات على يد
شبابنا
وشعبنا هناك امكانات كبيره في ايران وهم
يدركون ذلك ويعلمون ان شعبنا يملك الاراده
وباقي الشعوب كذلك اذا كانت تفكر
باستقلالها وحريتها فيجب ان تعلم ان هذا
الامر سيتحقق عبر مواجهه الظلم الولايات
المتحده اخطات في حساباتها في افغانستان
والعراق والمنطقه وارتكبت اخطاء في الكثير
من بقاء العالم واهدافها لن تتحقق بشان
شرق اوسط جديد امريكا تخيلت انها قادره
على التحكم بالشعوب عبر فرض ارادتها عليهم
وهذا ليس صحيحا قوتنا لا تكمن في اسلحتنا
بل في المنطق الذي نمتلكه وفي مواقفنا
العادله وهذا هو سبب حب شعوب المنطقه
للجمهوريه الاسلاميه الايرانيه اسلحتنا
ليست السبب وراء قوتنا الولايات المتحده
تمتلك اسلحه كثيره وكنا نملك سلاحا قبل
الثوره لكن ما يفتح المجال امام الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه في المنطقه هو المنطق والرساله
التي تحملها من
وقل ولهذا السبب بالذ نحن ندعم حركه
المقاومه في فلسط ونطقه جمهور اسلام امروز
رمشو برشته و به هم دلل ما حام جان مقاومت
هست فخامه
الرس السيد ابراهيم رئيسي شكرا لك على هذه
المقابله مع شبكه الجزيره والساده
المشاهدين الشكر ايضا موصول لكم دمتم بخير
والى اللقاء